so something as serious as the
impeachment of a sitting president
really shouldn't depend on public
opinion there have been a two
impeachments of presidents Andrew
Johnson and Bill Clinton neither was
ultimately convicted by the Senate but
it's still really serious stuff if
impeachment is the right thing based on
the facts both Republicans and Democrats
should do it regardless of party and
regardless of public opinion
now that's idealism and it's not based
in reality it's not the system that we
have our elected officials are highly
partisan on what even is worthy of
impeachment they're also completely
influenced by what the public wants at
any particular point in time and a
really great example is to look at
Richard Nixon's resignation Nixon
resigned because he was going to get
impeached he was going to get impeached
because Democrats and Republicans in his
own party were going to impeach him and
there was bipartisan impeachment support
in the House and Senate because there
was more and more public support from
both sides for impeachment so that
brings us to 2019 and in Donald Trump's
case in 2019 Republicans at least for
the time being still don't want to
impeach Donald Trump and Democrats do
but support among independent voters has
doubled since May or almost doubled
since April rather back in April 14
percent of independents said we should
impeach Donald Trump there's a new
Marist NPR PBS Newshour poll where
independent support for impeaching Trump
has almost doubled from 14 percent in
April to 23 percent now almost doubled
in two or three months two months this
is huge for two different reasons and
neither is that Trump is actually going
to be impeached and removed before the
November election he's not okay that's
not the goal we should set our
expectations correctly as I suggested we
do a week or two ago independence
doubling their support of Donald Trump
being impeached is huge because it's
pushed total support of impeachment
nationally over 50% to 52% that is huge
okay this is starting to be a historical
high 52 percent of the country believes
that the Pres
the United States should be impeached
and removed from office
that's massive and we have by and large
independence to thank for it
because both Democratic and Republican
support for impeachment has stayed
roughly the same for several months the
second reason that impeachment support
doubling among independents is huge is
that it means independence themselves
are moving away from Trump for the 2020
election and that could end up making
the difference in terms of who actually
wins in November of 2020 because we know
that Democrats aren't voting for Trump
mostly we know Republicans are voting
for Trump
mostly I know that every election we say
independent so they're going to make it
how will they vote all of that stuff
they're really going to be the
difference makers if support for
impeaching Trump doubles among
independents it is very reasonable to
think that just a few percent of
independents have shifted from a Trump
vote for 2020 to eight not Trump vote in
2020 in the last couple of months and
that's bad for Trump in 2020 and I want
to backtrack one one second here and
refresh about if impeachment conviction
isn't the goal why is it that we want
impeachment proceedings the whole point
here is to publicize the content of the
Moller report okay the Moller report
found substantial evidence that Donald
Trump obstructed on eight of 14 counts
that the Moller report looked at we need
public impeachment hearings we need
testimony we need the content of the
Moller report publicized we need all of
it it will not get Republicans to
convict Donald Trump and remove him
before November of 2020 unless something
incredibly unpredictable happens I just
don't see it happening it will however
pierced the echo chamber of those who
believed the entire bar letter no
collusion no obstruction propaganda
talking point most people in the Fox
News bubble have no idea how
disastrously damaging the content of the
Moller report was because most people in
the Fox News bubble and by the way a lot
of Americans in general haven't actually
read the content of the Moller report
impeachment hearings will expose that it
was 70
votes in three states that led to Donald
Trump defeating Hillary Clinton in 2016
those impeachment proceedings and
starting with the inquiry most
importantly should start right away and
all of this information should be
publicized if you think I'm wrong let me
know